ne pas laisser à leur enfant c'est ça
leur héritage moi mon père me ferait un
coup comme ça je ne lui adresse plus la
parole
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les stars qui ne veulent pas d'enfants
encore une masero donc effectivement
j'ai jamais eu voulu d'enfant j'ai subi
des interruptions volontaires de
grossesse je ne veux pas imposer la
personne que je suis Valérie Lemercier
elle elle a dit que c'est parce qu'elle
pouvait pas mais malgré tout elle dit
j'ai pas pu avoir d'enfant mais je ne
porte pas
l'envie d'être mère de toutes les
manières je vais être dépendant de rien
ni personne c'est pour ça aussi je crois
que j'ai pas fait d'enfant parce que je
pourrais pas assumer cette dépendance
c'est impossible qui prennent la
décision des de généthys tu sais
on n'est pas là forcément pour mettre
bas un jour etc qui lisent les articles
ont pas forcément besoin d'avoir des de
lire de voir des gens qui se répandent
sur ce sujet avec cette espèce de de
nonchalance qui peut être un peu gênante
mais alors des charges rajouterai un
truc c'est que c'est vrai que nous les
journalistes le premier truc qu'on fait
souvent quand on est interviewe une
femme de plus de 30 ans c'est de
demander est-ce que vous voulez des
enfants est-ce que vous regrettez de pas
avoir d'enfants etc donc ils sont un peu
obligés de répondre donc c'est pas
forcément comment
il y a aussi beaucoup d'actrices qui
disent ce monde est trop dur je ne veux
pas leur laisser ce monde et qui en
offre quand on dit navet et ça m'est
déjà arrivé elle te dise je veux pas de
vergetures je veux pas des seins qui
tombent je veux pas abîmer mon corps je
suis actrice je suis actrice Jean-Michel
maire qui connaît les femmes bah bien
sûr excuse-moi moi le fait qu'elles
veulent pas d'enfant j'ai absolument
rien contre chacun fait ce qu'il veut
moi c'est les raisons évoquer qui me
semble absolument incroyable le fait
Chimène Badi je veux pas que mon corps
c'est bien c'est bien un mec qui parle
mais oui c'est honnête mais c'est ce
qu'on est bien un homme
excuse-moi il y a rien de plus beau pour
une femme que ou pour un père bah j'ai
des enfants
c'est pas du tout la vie de Jean-Michel
je pense que d'abord premièrement
longtemps on a culpabilisé femme qui
n'avait pas non absolument c'était
limite une onde sociale absolument et
ben pour une fois qu'on les pubisent
moins je trouve ça génial il y a aucune
raison de vouloir absolument tu peux
respecter le choix de femme qui disent
voilà c'est une charge non parce que
c'est facile les paroles de mecs comme
tu fais là tu sais très bien et de notre
génération la charge mentale des enfants
sont souvent les femmes qui l'ont c'est
pas les mecs qui vont c'est pas les mecs
à l'école qui gèrent les mecs qui gère
les petits bobos ça c'est nouveau dans
la nouvelle génération c'est très bien
mais la plupart du temps c'est des
femmes qui s'occupaient de ça il y a une
phrase pardon la phrase la plus
intelligente que je trouvais sur ce
plateau c'est Philippe si tu penses que
tu es là c'est pas normal
dégueulasse à ton enfant pareil le père
est responsable de dire c'est parce que
ce monde est pourri j'ai pas envie de
laisser les enfants moi l'homme et la
femme se pose la même question d'accord
certain et donc je suis pas une femme je
sais pas quel est le si on vraiment un
désir ou si c'est un devoir à un moment
donné moi je pense qu'on le fait un
moment donné dans sa vie plus tard avec
le temps je pense qu'il y a des regrets
après on se laisse croire que non je
n'en voulais pas parce qu'elles sont pas
ça à côté mais je pense que le fait
d'avoir un enfant deux hommes qui
parlent moi je pense que la maternité tu
l'as encore ou pas pour avoir un enfant
que ce soit l'homme l'enfant c'est quand
même le sujet qui fait Benoît on a envie
de vieillir accompagné on a envie
d'avoir on a envie de d'échanger
d'apprendre
Benoît je te coupe une seconde parce que
Isa évidemment c'est intéressant aussi
on parle de désir de maternité donc
Isaac si j'ai bien compris ne voulait
pas d'enfants elle en a eu un mois
on écoute une femme je ne voulais pas
d'enfant et contrairement à ce que tu
dis c'est beaucoup plus mal accepté une
femme qui ne veut pas d'enfant qu'une
femme qui veut des enfants une femme qui
veut des enfants passe pour altruiste et
puis quelque part c'est son devoir une
femme qui fait pas d'enfant de
qu'est-ce qu'elle égoïste c'est ça je
n'ai jamais ressenti de désir d'en avoir
que ton enfant ne sait jamais sorti
désiré jamais senti aimer je l'ai eu je
l'ai eu par hasard et donc il avait un
temps de psy je l'ai accepté non non je
vais te l'accepter c'est gentil j'ai pas
déposé j'ai
[Applaudissements]
vidéo gag
j'ai gagné un caméscope 100 euros
parce que j'aurais pu ne pas le garder
parce qu'on arrête pas de dire
alors
excusez-moi
une époque où les femmes n'arrêtaient
pas de dire je fais ce que je veux de
mon corps ce que je n'ai jamais pensé
donc j'aurais pu très bien ne pas le
garder tout ce que toutes mes copines me
conseillaient de faire les Ultra
féministes que je n'étais pas et moi je
me suis dit bon ben je l'ai je le garde
et j'ai adoré l'état de grossesse mais
les raisons qui fait que je n'avais pas
des vidéos d'enfants n'ont pas changé je
n'avais pas de désir d'enfant et en plus
effectivement j'étais traumatisé par la
démographie mondiale et je ne voulais
pas participer alors juste ce qui est
mon droit le plus strict d'abord moi
j'ai toujours voulu avoir des enfants
moi mes parents ont pas pu avoir
d'enfant donc ma mère a dû adopter donc
j'ai été adopter donc voilà c'est une
histoire
ignorais bébé
mais vous me faites des hits dans cette
phrase dans cette émission
elle a fait beaucoup de fausses couches
et il y avait une pression sociale c'est
vrai à l'époque bon voilà c'était il y a
45 ans mais aujourd'hui aussi je trouve
qu'il y a plein de jeunes filles à qui
on dit il y a cette espèce de
d'injonction à être mère absolument et
on peut ne pas avoir le désir moi
j'avais un désir absolu quoi de
peut-être de par mon histoire j'en sais
rien mais je voulais je savais que je
voulais être maman et je suis une super
maman donc genre c'est mon job préféré
quoi j'adore ça
[Rires]
les accepter allez il y a aussi une
question de je suis d'accord de regard
sur la vie aussi moi je trouve la vie
tellement belle je crois qu'on a
tellement de chance j'avais envie de
transmettre ça quoi je suis pas du tout
dans un truc où je me dis ah c'est naze
très bien
iris mitner absolument irrita
avant une soirée qui a mal tourné
la plupart de ces revenus viennent de
l'influence donc elle est beaucoup
beaucoup sur les réseaux mais elle se
fait beaucoup critiquer forcément la 3
millions de d'abonnés et notamment sur
son physique parce que certains disent
que ça bouge ses yeux ont changé qu'elle
fait de la chirurgie esthétique et elle
en fait ou pas quelle année elle a dit
non non regardez les photos en 2017
c'était ma bouche etc et elle en profite
aussi pour vanter les crèmes et certains
produits qu'elle utilisent et qui lui
peut-être SMS qui était super drôle
c'est que quand on était énergie 12
Stéphane Joffre que j'embrasse qui était
le patron un jour convoque Benoît il lui
dit et il lui dit ah oui s'il te plaît
ne fais pas la bouche c'est trop voyant
il a jamais fait la bouche voilà c'était
il m'a dit arrête de faire gonfler
l'élève c'est horrible à l'antenne c'est
la seule chose qui est naturel chez moi
c'était super drôle
à quoi correspond ce chiffre 275
millions me répondaient pas une semaine
d'anouna c'est pas drôle
un héritage
c'est l'acteur Aston Kutcher et my la
connaît qui aurait volé ne pas laisser à
leur enfant c'est ça leur
héritage et elle dit même carrément je
ne veux pas que les enfants soient des
connards
mes enfants n'auront pas grand chose ils
n'auront ils n'auront juste leur nom on
finira par donner notre argent à des
associations à différents organismes
s'ils veulent se lancer dans leur propre
entreprise qui le fassent pardon c'est
être pas lunettes voilà et je ne veux
pas c'est déjà cette phrase je ne veux
pas que mes enfants deviennent des
connards
est-ce que ça vous choque tout ça oui
pourquoi ben je sais pas s'ils sont bien
élevés je vous vois pourquoi l'argent
ferait de des connards déjà c'est il
faut que l'éducation soit fait à la base
l'argent ne rentre pas mais en même
temps
ça va devenir un connard déjà moi je
pars pas de ce principe là je pense que
c'est l'éducation est fait l'argent n'a
rien à voir avec ceci et après c'est
vrai que quand bien même ils auront le
nom de leurs parents ça va quand même
rouler c'était oui mais il leur laisse
rien de rien pas de maison
un projet
qui se débrouille et oui moi j'ai mal à
la vie de Philippe moi sinon je leur
file mon RIB et puis je veux bien
devenir un connard
aujourd'hui à peu près ton capital 5
millions 10 millions
ça donne déjà un indice si tu enlèves
tes dettes ce que tu as toi ce qui te
reste à la maison et tout déjà j'ai pas
de dette ah bah voilà donc j'ai des
crédits
ça s'appelle des dettes
c'est un capital patrimoine de 2
millions 2 millions à peu près bien tu
laisseras tout à tes enfants de toute
façon si je crève vaut mieux que ce soit
eux qui les récupère mais de toute façon
avec le film association tu pourrais
donner on peut pas chez nous
c'était tout c'était tout le débat
justement
tu peux faire ça en France tu peux pas
et à tous aussi les tirages qui la
semaine dernière si on était prêt à
Philippe Philippe il aime bien faire des
blagues mais ce que vous savez pas non
plus c'est qu'il se bat et il s'est
battu dernièrement pour une patinoire
dans une petite ville ne ferme pas pour
que les mots puissent faire du sport pas
de bêtises et tout ça
[Rires]
moi mon père me ferait un coup comme ça
je ne lui adresse plus la parole arrête
de mon vivant de son vivant il annonce
je ne laisserai rien mes enfants qui se
démerdent je ne lui adresse
quelque chose j'ai été très pote avec un
fils du cacao je vous dirai pas qui je
n'avais jamais vu ça de ma vie quand
l'argent remplace l'éducation il était
au dieu il parlait mal aux jambes il
savait pas il savait pas ce que c'était
il avait aucune notion de rien 500000
quand tu as pas bossé tu sais pas ce que
c'est que bosser ça 500000 c'est pas
toujours
c'est un cas particulier enfin moi mes
enfants ils sont dans une école où il y
a pas mal de gosses de riches et de fils
à pape etc bon parce que j'ai voulu leur
donner cette éducation là et je veux
qu'il soit dans cette dans cette école
là donc ils sont avec les fils d'eux les
machins et les enfants si vous êtes
devant chez vous ce que j'ai voulu qu'il
soit contre riche et personne bien mais
je voulais que ça dans une école
bilingue moi il se trouve que voilà
c'est fréquenté par ce genre de délites
on va dire
c'est la vérité et il y a plein
d'enfants qui sont adorables moi tous
les copains de maison de mes enfants ils
sont adorables ils sont bien élevés non
mais ils ont la notion de l'argent c'est
pas des connards
vous avez l'esprit français démago ou
l'argent s'écrade où il faut pas gagner
pas du tout il faut toujours tout cacher
on demande à un tel qu'est-ce qui gagne
qu'est-ce qui truc pour voir s'il a pas
quelque chose bon voilà moi
j'ai pas envie d'en parler
tu gagnes combien tu es payé ici tu fais
quoi
arrêtez de déléguer les questions
j'ai aucune envie ben voilà tu parles
pas pourquoi je le dis pas pourquoi tu
le dis pas pourquoi tu gagnes par mois
d'attiser
2022 tu dis ou
tes virus
sensible
nous explique l'argent
sur Instagram et Instagram c'est vrai
que ça paye bien au fond là tu fais des
partenariats
par rapport à Stan quecher et qui eux
pour revenir à eux on éducation bien
spéciale ils offrent aucun cadeau non
plus à Noël à leurs enfants il est oui
c'est parti non c'est tous les à côté
juste pour dire qu'il y a beaucoup de
milliardaires américains des stars des
hommes d'affaires qui ont décidé de ne
pas filer leur fortune Bill Gates a déjà
donné 90%
et certains pensent que c'est mieux de
faire ça et qu'il est que quelques
millions de dollars à leurs enfants pas
forcément aux États-Unis à ce côté il y
a ce côté tu veux tu veux réussir tu
réussir mais vous savez pas Donald Trump
détester il était milliardaire avant
d'être président François Hollande a un
contre lui n'a jamais eu un CDD ou un
CDI de sa vie il n'a jamais travaillé il
a fait l'ENA et homme politique comment
veux-tu qu'il sache beaucoup de
politiciens comment gérer une société à
ma chaîne il n'a jamais eu un CDD jamais